this episode is sponsored by google play
with the help of Disney frozen
adventures
[Music]
before you skip Gretel in Hansel
returned to a time when every studio was
scrambling for a franchise and Universal
Pictures wrote down the names of every
public domain fairy tale then added but
ready to the end until something clicked
Snow White
but ready I mean Snow White and the
Huntsman and the Huntsman winters war
you may think you know Snow White you do
but this ain't your daddy's Disney story
because Snow White is the colorful fairy
tale and these movies are Grey's
nightmares but that won't stop the movie
from over explaining the old snow-white
lore under explaining newer Dumber Snow
White lore and doing a sequel full of
even newer Dumberer Huntsman stuff okay
we get it
magic mirrors poison apples blah blah
blah you were gonna tell us how birds
poop fairies cool strap in for the
fantasy adventure you can make yourself
if your D&D crew was on xanax and me the
ASMR of fantasy casts like the Huntsman
Chris Hemsworth Ernest combo of William
Wallace Shrek and Stewie Griffin why
didn't you tell me what you tend to do
with them or who's she why are you
putting so much emphasis on the H my
wife cou quit
he'll team up with Snow White a princess
with three whole facial expressions
scared tremble smile tremble and back of
head tremble his wife whose death was a
major part of his character development
until he drops know why from the sequel
and they needed a replacement love
interest Prince how you like them apples
and the dwarves who wait is that a
McShane Toby Jones what are you doing
here this was Bob Hoskins last role and
I haven't seen actors this good to dwarf
a since tiptoes together they'll fight
Charlize Theron who embodies the Eddie
Redmayne screen whispers green school
ability a power you have wasted on
nothing but cheap sentiment
and her sister Freya a lady with ice
powers who hides away in a frozen castle
because she couldn't let it go hmm I
wonder where they got that idea or that
idea she is the more that idea or that
idea or that idea or that idea got milk
so sit through two films made to please
an executive who kept yelling mega Lord
of the Rings at his interns until it
happened but would just insult that
franchises fans with its
paint-by-numbers CGI in battles bore
Game of Thrones fans with its stingless
romance irritate Harry Potter fans with
a boring toilets world of magic and
disappoint Witcher fans were not
including any coin tossing Bob's
does it going to your Witcher
do-do-do-do-do-do out in oh yeah these
movies are terrible starring and
Asgardian axe Guardian princess monotone
a bomb spell Pixar's brave part Elsa I
mean Freya Queen Freya totally different
character yep it's just bad Honey I
Shrunk the Brits Snow White Knight and
Little Nicky whack mirror
what does the mirror show you what do
you see okay how you gonna have Liam
Neeson do voice work and then never have
them on screen
don't you Liam bait me this episode is
sponsored by google play get Disney
frozen adventures and discover more on
Google Play he's not the Messiah he's a
very naughty boy
now go away these young guys are playing
checkers I'm out there playing chess
every 60 seconds a minute passes in
Africa